I'm Raymond Arroyo in for Laura Ingram
this is a special edition of the Ingram
angle from New York City we have a big
show for you tonight in moments Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis will react
exclusively to Biden's divisive and
frankly dark speech about America and
later I'll go golfing with actors Mark
Wahlberg Kevin Dillon plus boxing greats
Sugar Ray Leonard and Evander Holyfield
I promise you will not want to miss the
hijinks stick around but first it
appears that President Biden has
awakened from his hellish fever dream of
last night his nightmarish speech which
looked like he'd either wandered onto
the set of Triumph of the will or into
Amsterdam's red light district is all
over now today he has no memory of it
watching all of this recalled that
moment at the end of the musical 1776
when John Adams prowls Independence Hall
in frustration
is anybody there
does anybody care
does anybody see what I see
Biden would probably call Adams an
extremist but is anybody there does the
president even know what he's saying you
decide I'm not going to comment you
watch this
but there's no question
that the Republican party today is
dominated driven and intimidated
by Donald Trump and the Maggie
Republicans
and that is a threat to this country
Trump and the Maggie Republicans
represented extremism that threatens the
very foundations of our Republic and
Maggie Republicans are just to
destroying American democracy clean up
on Pennsylvania Avenue please whoever
put the president up to this should be
fired now my suspicion is that after the
Ferocious backlash to this speech the
staffer is responsible or Biden himself
made the decision to backtrack even the
ratings prove what a bust this speech
was but it did confirm why 75 percent of
Democrats in a recent CNN poll want a
candidate other than Biden in 2024 and
why his approval is it 42 percent but
the nagging question remains is anybody
there hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else